[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight i'm jesse waters in for
tucker not many people were watching joe
biden's town hall last night the ratings
were absolutely terrible which isn't
surprising at all joe biden's not
capable of thinking clearly and most
americans recognize that so they watched
football and fox news instead but that
raises an interesting question which
until recently no one has asked given
the obvious deterioration of joe biden's
mind he now struggles to form coherent
sentences
why have this town hall at all
why not call another lid at 10 am and
send joe biden off to the farm in
delaware one of the few people who tuned
in last night a novelist named walter
kern offered a possible explanation
quote i've never seen anything like this
kern wrote at some level it has to be
intentional no one was clamoring for a
town hall grave deterioration is being
thrust in our face
cooper is racing through his question as
though to keep from laughing
it feels like the work of enemy
propagandists
kern made that observation a response to
this clip from last night's town hall
which we promise
we haven't edited in any way
with just in terms of inflation because
you had told
us at a town hall i think it was in july
that the in this was just near-term
inflation
the wall street journal recently talked
to like 67
uh financial experts who said that they
they saw high inflation going all the
way or deep into 2022.
joe biden just stands there for nearly
20 seconds with his hands locked in the
nine o'clock and three o'clock position
watching that it's hard not to wonder
did joe biden know where he was
did he think he was piloting one of
those old amtrak trains right there on
stage
did he convince himself he was really
back on the mean streets of delaware
driving his 67 stingray to a throw down
with corn pop
aviators and metal chain in tow
the road in joe biden's mind was
obviously long and treacherous hence the
clenched grip
the moderator on the stage as walter
kern pointed out tried his hardest not
to notice any of this
but it was noticeable to everybody who
watched the town hall last night
joe biden's handlers knew something like
this would happen and they sent him out
there anyway
things became so confusing for joe biden
last night at one point he literally
stopped mid-sentence and asked and we're
quoting what am i doing here
forty percent of all products coming
into the united states of america on the
west coast go through
uh los angeles and uh and uh um uh um
what am i doing here is it long beach
long beach thank you
obviously it's not joe biden's fault
he's in mental decline but the political
opportunists who made joe biden
president of the united states people
like jill biden and susan rice and so on
are responsible for this they lied for
years about joe biden's conditions so
that they could obtain more power now
that they have that power they're making
us aware who's really in charge it's not
joe biden
the point of last night's town hall was
to make that undeniable
he doesn't have any comprehension of any
of the problems this country is facing
asked about the fact that hundreds of
thousands of illegal immigrants are
entering this country unimpeded for
example joe biden started lying
uncontrollably
first he claimed he's been to the border
and knows it well
but there's no record joe biden's ever
visited the southern border not his
president not his vice president not his
senator and not as a citizen
today fox's peter ducey asks joe biden's
flack
about that
there's been a reporting that he
did drive through the border when he was
on the campaign trail in 2008 and he is
certainly familiar with the fact and it
stuck with him with the fact that uh in
el paso uh the border goes right through
the center of town
so we looked into this in 2008 joe biden
flew into el paso and then drove to new
mexico for a political rally he never
visited the border he didn't even drive
through it
if joe biden saw the border at all it
was in his rear-view mirror so this is
just another lie
but even if you believe the lie the
white house's explanation still makes no
sense
they're saying joe biden drove through
the border one time more than a decade
ago on his way to somewhere else
according to the white house that means
he's an expert and he doesn't have any
reason to visit the border now that he's
president of the united states
this is so absurd that it's obvious no
one in the white house really believes
it
again
they're rubbing this in our faces
joe biden is not in control
that's why none of these excuses make
any sense not a single one
at the town hall last night joe biden
offered a totally different explanation
he said he can't visit the border
because he's just too busy
do you have plans to visit the southern
border i've been there before and i
haven't i mean i know it well i guess i
should go down but the
but the whole point of it is i haven't
had a whole hell of a lot of time to get
down joe biden doesn't have time to
visit the border
meanwhile according to the white house
joe biden is going to spend this weekend
on vacation in delaware
the only conclusion anybody can
reasonably draw from all of this is that
joe biden isn't really running things
and joe biden himself at various points
last night admitted that
asked about inflation including higher
gas prices joe biden straight up
acknowledged that he has no idea what to
do about it
do you have a timeline for gas prices
when you think they may start coming
down
my guess is you'll start to see gas
prices come down
as we get by and going into the winter i
mean excuse me in the next year in 2022
i don't see anything that's going to
happen in the meantime it's going to
significantly reduce gas prices i don't
have a near-term answer i don't have a
near-term answer
in reality joe biden's handlers have
been begging opec to produce more oil
and send it to us and they've been
refusing that's the real near-term
answer and it's been a disaster this
country was energy independent when joe
biden took office and it's not anymore
it's not clear joe biden realizes that
but if there's one thing joe biden knows
well it's had to deflect from his own
failures
that's instinctual for joe biden he
doesn't even need to know where he is or
what's happening around him he'll just
do it so last night joe biden identified
the real threat this country's facing
first responders and police officers
they're refusing to take the covid
vaccine so they're to blame for all
that's wrong with america joe biden said
and they should be fired
as many as as one in three emergency
responders in some cities like chicago
los angeles right here in baltimore are
refusing to comply
with city vaccine mandates
i'm wondering where you stand on that
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be
stay at home or let go yes and yes
you hear that applause right there and
you realize that a lot of people are
willing to put up with a dementia
patient in the white house as long as he
destroys their political opponents
last night's town hall demonstrated
among other things that authoritarianism
is far more popular in the democratic
party than most americans realize
remember when donald trump warned the
democrats were going to start destroying
statues of our founding fathers
donald trump was mocked for that
but last night joe biden said he'd be
okay with destroying statues of thomas
jefferson and no one even batted an eye
new york city is removing a statue of
thomas jefferson from its legislative
chamber because of jefferson's history
as a slave
slave holder
do you support that decision well i
think that's up to the locality to
decide what they want to do on that
thomas jefferson was the principal
author of the declaration of
independence the document that freed
americans from great britain
now a lot of democrats want thomas
jefferson's statute destroyed and joe
biden isn't going to stop them
are you surprised by that you shouldn't
be
at one point the town hall audience last
night laughed at the very idea of
freedom
you want your constitutional and
god-given right to self-determination
joe biden and his followers think it's a
punch line
look
the two things that concern me
one are those who just try to make this
a political issue freedom
i have the freedom to kill you
with my kobe no i mean come on freedom
this kind of thing happened again and
again later on joe biden again suggested
getting rid of the filibuster and the
crowd loved it
as long as he's talking about crushing
his political enemies they're on board
they'll forgive anything even obvious
lies for weeks joe biden has claimed
that this network fox news mandates that
its employees take the covid shot
that's never been true but last night
joe biden once again repeated the lie
things i find do you realize they
mandate vaccinations
at fox headquarters yeah
i find that mildly fascinating
mildly mildly fascinating and the crowd
just nods their heads the moderator
agrees no one corrects the lie to be
clear not a single person has been fired
from fox for refusing to get vaccinated
period
after this town hall two things are
clear first joe biden's not capable of
thinking clearly and most americans
recognize that you can't watch these
clips and come to any other conclusion
but as a way to signal the authority of
our actual leaders the authoritarians
who write the executive orders and pass
the legislation last night's town hall
was an unequivocal success
it turns out that their agenda
is more popular among democrats than we
thought
many democrats now applaud
disinformation they cheer for
authoritarianism
they don't care if their dictator lies
about visiting the border or thinks he's
driving a car in the middle of a
nationally televised town hall they just
want a dictator
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else